okay so a few of you have come up with
an on top let me let me walk you through
this one because again it requires a bit
of different thinking we're so used to
finding an answer like we'll just tell
me the value and then you know you get a
number at the end you're like okay okay
and you can test it out with
inequalities things are a little more
flexible okay as I'm really going to
demonstrate over here will come to
example three two seconds so remember I
said to you before we've dealt with
simultaneous equations in the past but
these guys are simultaneous inequalities
the first thing you do when you
encounter simultaneous equations is
you've got to be able to name them right
you've got to be able to talk about
which ones which so that's the very
first thing we're going to do I just
give them labels so that I can refer to
each one okay from then on in I have to
make some choices and this is by the way
very important because you guys know
especially we used to meet your problems
but all the time in mathematics you've
got to be able to communicate clearly
I'm not just going to launch you to some
algebra I'm going to say what am i doing
like where am i starting from right so
that's why I've given these labels I'm
actually going to start with inequality
number two right so if I at least say
and I think you should as well don't
just have a statement which comes out of
nowhere tell me where it's begun
particular you've got three to choose
from I need to know which one if I just
start by writing that out one of the
reasons why I've started with this one
rather than say equation one is it's
what we call an inequality in one
variable you notice it's only got X's in
it by the same logic equation sorry
inequality 3 only has one variable in
it's only got dead inequality one has
two variables x and y so immediately
it's more complicated and I look at
anything I'll come back to that one and
I will equal inequality two though it's
not too bad you can see I can subtract
6x from both sides which would leave you
with this I can subtract 19 from both
sides which would leave me with this how
does that look you're comfortable with
that okay at this point I've already
seen before I'm going to divide by a
negative number namely negative 4 so
that leaves me with this
but what happens to the inequality
fantastic so it spits around now this
result here it's nice and simple I don't
know how big X is in relation to y&z yet
but I know how big it is in relation to
one so I can't go any further in terms
of simplifying this I'm going to call
this 2a now I could have called an
inequality for I could have called it in
equality a t1 if I wanted to and maybe
you've chosen some kind of naming system
I like to choose a naming system which
helps me know where this inequality came
from that helps me not like especially
we've got lots to deal with not double
back on myself and like which one's am I
dealt with again it also stops you
substituting an equation or inequality
back into itself which is not a good
idea so now I'm done with two I'm going
to have got three why am I going after
three again and not one it's only got
one variable in it so it's going to be
simpler to deal with okay it's even
easier than inequality - I'm going to
[Music]
what shall I do
subtract 6 from both sides like that and
then I can divide both sides by negative
5 which again switches this round okay
now this is inequality 3 and now you can
see a picture signed form do you notice
this I don't have any statement that has
X or Z together but if you think about
these two at the same time because they
are simultaneous after all they do see
something together right I guess the way
you could write this is like so if you
combine equality to a equality 3 a you
can actually have an order here right
which is the smallest number in this
scheme then that is less than 1 and 1 in
turn is less than X do you agree but
what that tells you is that Z is less
than X right because actually only
interested really worry about 1 you can
clearly see the order that this is going
in does that make sense
so I'll just file that in the back of my
mind the last inequality that I have to
get information out of is the first one
so
1 what shall I do I'll subtract
excellent and then lastly I'll divide an
again because they're trying to get you
to get a handle on this I've got to make
sure this inequality switches around so
I get this and now our picture is
complete isn't it because I know which
is bigger out of Z and X and now I know
which is bigger out of x and y so
therefore I can say from let's name this
one a let's name this one this is a bit
tricky because it comes from different
spots I guess I'll call it to be that'll
do from one a and to be I can say Z is
less than X I could say that there's a 1
in there but I don't need 2 is less than
Y therefore Y is largest ok are there
any questions on that before we have a
go at the next one you comfortable with
the idea so you can see immediately the
logic of equation inequality is
different to the logic of equations but
there are a lot of commonalities